hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to CP containment
breach this game you know I never
thought that this game would have
provided as much entertainment as it has
but it keeps getting better you know if
uh I would suggest to the maker of this
game that he puts it up on Steam early
access even if it's still free and I you
know he could probably make money off of
this one it's so great such a great
horror game but I'm just saying like if
he put it up on Steam for early access
as any good uh hi Billy where'd you come
from [ __ ] huh
oh hi mr. skull what is that okay anyway
he could put it up there and then it
probably got a lot more exposure and a
lot more support and it would allow him
up allow the community to be able to
edit stuff in the Steam Workshop it
would probably be a really good idea for
uh the growth of this game because there
are a lot okay who's that all about cuz
there are a lot of things that could be
done by mater s'en there's a lot of
modders out there working where is he
why does he just like up here randomly
in the most asinine of places and snap
my neck what does he do that what's the
purpose of doing that
okay I just whoo-hooo did he come from
before seen here did that Co mega silo I
can close that up where did he come from
where did he go where did he come from
tonight Joe and I apologize again for my
voice I'm just being very delicate with
it right now because it's it's it's on
the very cusp of just going completely
so I just need to be very delicate with
it okay no I tried containing radical
Larry didn't seem to take maybe nine
tailed fox got to what I'm trying to do
is I'm trying to get back to that tree
because someone said that after the
remote door control was turned off I
could get to it so that's what I do
okay I'm backtracking a lot right now
now I don't remember exactly where it
was ah here it is good good good good
so that means that I can booyah
here Cheers actually let me not save
right now hello mr. tree what are you
gonna do for me what do i do what do i
do it's a tree what do I do
I touched the trees bark okay
okay and what and what now I'm a little
confused what do I do seriously what do
I do
I touched its bark what does that mean
does that mean it's gonna grow a me cuz
I oh like oh maybe no need of water no I
don't know maybe I need to do some of
this I don't know what it wants from me
what does it want from me I don't know
okay I'm confused I there was some
reason that someone wanted me to go back
to this and I can't see it if someone
wants to explain go right ahead but I'm
moving forward should I have touched it
is that a bad thing if I touched it oh
well I saved two lake all right we're
headed back to the gate B we're gonna
get out of this sumbitch we're gonna
escape and run wild and free across the
plains of Mombasa
I keep feeling like what I did was a bad
thing maybe okay I think what I have to
do is I have to turn on remote door
fuckbag where were you
god dammit oh god damn Oh
oh god damn it oh my god ah 173 scariest
monster ever made in any game ever you
know just for the shirt just for the
pure surprise factor huh the ultimate
jump scare cuz you don't know when he's
coming oh and my voice is almost
completely gone so I'm gonna be it was
like the last leg for me okay where am I
oh crap I'm back here alright whatever
whatever I know the way to go I think
yeah okay oh my god I still I don't know
where he came from it was that same room
that he got me before my complete
surprise he must have been hiding in the
walls or something it's just over this
way right I think so where is he
ah there you are you giant douche you
[ __ ] back master
you asked back master Holson you master
of asses
okay all right who dokie
let us continue on now all we have to do
is we have to get who's that we have to
go all the way back all the way back you
know what I haven't found yet and I've
been through almost the entire facility
now I haven't found the machine the
clockwork machine that lets me build
anything I haven't found it and that's
very weird cuz usually that's like the
first thing that you find okay not that
way this way then go spray through the
door then go to the other side alright
save okay nothing Bad's gonna happen
nothing bad is gonna happen
I am the utmost professional of this
game and nothing bad is gonna happen
nothing bad alright this store is still
a little weird that's okay
lets me go through mr. doose isn't here
anyone
okay so far so good so far so good can't
complain everything's going swimmingly
not dead yet oh crap did I look I didn't
look no I didn't look and I'm not gonna
look not gonna look not gonna look mr.
douche isn't here again good
hey so far so good
all right no incidents so far is
everyone extremely weirded out that
nothing has happened yet cuz I am where
am I now
good what was over this way oh yeah
that's right so far so good it was our
guide hey
so far so good so far so good
what was over this way oh yeah here we
go here we go so far so good so far so
good
I don't detect a Billy thank you sir
don't do that I know how you work there
we go got it you just trying to startle
me a little bit it's okay
and now so far so good I'm gonna make it
I'm gonna make it I very rarely get the
gate be exit I very rarely do and I
think I remember where to go for that I
very rarely get the gate be exit I think
I've only gotten it once in my entire
time playing this game I've only got it
once okay so that's right is this way I
think
I think I'm gonna make it I think I'm
gonna make it I really think I'm gonna
make it Oh Oh Mike I can't save in this
okay so that's okay I understand
oh my god it's gate B holy hell
holy hell in a handbasket oh my god I
made it here oh my god right with my
voice was dying
whoa and I did not I did not
okay here we go
can't save in this location all right
I'm gonna get out all right huh this is
gonna be good
I'm almost entire Oh Oh go go go go go
go go go go gotta go gotta go
can't hit me can't hit me can't hit me
no no no no take my breath let make the
run no no no no no no no no
no no no no scp-682 just broke out at
gate B I want all available helicopters
an MTF units at Nate B now is where I
need watched scp-682 is unnecessary
helicopters and sticky
boy as my boy
yeah buddy my deck
alpha warheads in t-minus 90 seconds
they will go wash your eyes to board the
nearest helicopter or enter the nearest
blast shelter immediately
they gonna go off you [ __ ]
they ain't gonna go off I can tell you
that right now
and we're hey let me read this see three
paths she's engaging the target fly more
on their way from gate a what about
those MTF nine-tailed Fox still inside
ah yeah that's right they activated it
but it's not gonna blow and Babu's gay
oh my god yeah
lock it up baby oh wait
I don't think I was supposed to open
that yeah oh I'll be the way lose the
end I get to see a whole lot of nothing
happened
I guess it's just a waiting game until
then we were unable to detonate the
warheads for unknown reasons all
helicopters and TF units go back to
Gainey immediately capturing scp-682 is
now on number one priority hi how's it
going how you do it oh no no no no no no
no no no no no no what are you doing
what are you doing
I got a gas mask [ __ ] wait a minute
what's going on what happens now
Oh is he supposed to kill me am I
supposed to die is that the true ending
I just died well doesn't that suck balls
hey wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute what there's fine more stuff on
here now um no no no no okay nothing
there I guess that's the end of it oh
don't know what else I was supposed to
do but there you go
yeah the end of the game we found a dead
class T on the walkway outside gave me
he's got
soon he was shot when we were fighting
scp-682 I'd like to
class decayed past the gate
the Riverina security tapes from all the
cameras
find out who was stationed there
during 6-8 2's escape attempt there you
have it everybody that's sir
there you have it I didn't get every
room but that was probably the most
thorough play through the game I've ever
done in my life from start to finish
never cheating got through everything
great saw the X recipes it was wonderful
so anyway I'm putting this to rest until
the next time there was a major update
and I know that people always go like
you need to apply ojp more but I only
play it when there are major updates not
minor updates major updates so anyway
this is a wonderful game I love it to
the developers thank you so much for
giving me a great game to play so many
scares and whatnot I can't wait to see
what comes next so anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as all sir
he's got multiple gunshot wounds in his
chest I'd assume he was shouting we were
fighting scp-682 I'd like to know how
the hell did a class-d get past the gate
deliver me the security tapes from all
the
ah oh no okay all right then
there we go tiddlywinks hi
thanks again everyone see you in the
next one bye bye Joe Jack let's go buddy
guys
is anybody still there
good NRT
wait whoa wait go okay
wait sorry guys you're still out there
um something seems to